[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL GAUTHIER: With the
population growing on Earth
as well as the climate
changing a lot,
the amount of land that
we can use to grow plants
has been decreasing
over the past decades.
So by growing the
plants vertically,
on the same area of
land, we can actually
increase the production by
how many layers we put in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SETH LOVELACE: Our vertical farm
is just a hydroponic station.
But all of our different
members on the team,
we're trying to bring different
metrics, different ideas,
to really make the farm
work more efficiently.
A lot of people might
say, at my level,
math gets very abstract
and very rigorous.
So how can you really use
that to solve problems?
But I'd say, at
the core of math,
it's more of the approach
that really matters.
My project, in
particular, focuses
on how to analyze the
nutrient composition
of our hydroponic solution
in the vertical farm.
And we'd like to really alter
the nutrient composition
of this hydroponic
solution so that we can
grow bigger and better plants.
Our ultimate goal is to work to
make the farm fully automatic.
JESENIA HAYNES: I'm
growing lettuce and kale
in the vertical farm.
And I'm assessing the
environmental impacts
as it relates to the
Princeton campus.
So I'm measuring the
water and energy used.
I want to see if
Princeton, hypothetically,
uses this system to grow all of
their lettuce and kale needs,
how that would compare
to where they currently
buy their lettuce and kale
in terms of energy or water --
so track the miles
it takes to transport
the food here and sort of turn
that into a carbon footprint
and energy cost.
PAUL GAUTHIER: For
growing one lettuce,
you will probably need up
to 50 gallons of water.
And the reason of that is you
have to water them very often,
and the water runs off.
When in the vertical
farm we actually recycle
this water, and the first
result that we got from here
shows that we are
producing lettuce or kale
with 0.5 gallons of water.
SETH LOVELACE: The
accessibility of research
to undergraduates on this
campus is just amazing --
doing research in a lab,
getting hands-on experience,
and really learning in a
laboratory environment.
I'd say that's one of the most
valuable aspects of a Princeton
education, that you can
simply make something
like that happen.
JESENIA HAYNES: I would
like to find a career
or activity relating to ecological
conservation, sustainable
farming.
So I think this is
good for me because it
gets me thinking about what
I want to do for the future.
And it gets me exposed
to this type of farming.
PAUL GAUTHIER: All the
strains of Princeton
will combine into this project.
With all of that, we
hope that Princeton
will start leading the
field in vertical farm
by providing new insights
in terms of technologies,
but also training new
students for future consulting
companies that, sooner
than later, will probably
be asking for people
understanding vertical farming.
And then we can provide
data to the industry.